copy my haircut bro let's get snooze am
I on whose team my on waste it like it's
free-for-all you made it
oh god okay look at the traffic
Oh No shut your night I think the chat
go away so big God you got a sword wait
how do I use a sword
I have it what are you doing minx what
the hell I just picked up an umbrella
where is everyone
oh no that way let me reload let me Oh
let me reload please please hi hi hi hi
hi hi stop I don't shoot you fight you
guys that's what I thought come at me
bro God
Mindy the usual spot Boyan hey got any
bullets yeah that's what you get someone
teabagging in let's go teabag and
they'll be back like them so long I'm
doing come here you little [ __ ] no time
watch watch watch watch what what it was
[ __ ]
wait wait oh my soul oh oh yeah you keep
bailing knocking damn it wait
and that's how we do it in the purity
part time yeah I caught your little
dancer
what is this Donna the Compton thing
good oh yeah
sure down okay so this is like
elimination now last one standing if he
loves me
he's left everybody I'm alone hell yeah
it's pure duty veces oh you're my
nemesis gotta use this bad boy lately I
don't shoot no no no don't shoot
what do you minx do it but but I'm but
[ __ ] you right in second you are
[ __ ] bull I'm done in stall like I
just wake up the mill in nowhere and
you're like a bear sure uh yeah it's
done killing people Oh
this man's pretty cool yeah I play two
different one disgustingness discuss
this little song get it like make sure I
was innocent that host defenses Hey look
I'm a cop I had a ha I'm shut up I can't
even get to finish my sentence
steady how do you activate the shield do
this I love I'll clean my room you're
cleaning your room is that a good reason
not to kill you
Oh get up no come here come here
no yeah I just want to play with oh come
on let me play for gold together come on
Ruby miters together to Niners fi this
is a pickaxe I was gonna ha no I don't
like rent hi stop it's not doing ass
time
oh my god it's baby oh shoot oh teach
you my my guy stuff does get epic I
don't see dinner she has no life left
ah yeah that's what I'm talking about
the water Chuck I like I'm Adam still
rubbing his ass oh this is what I'm
talking about this is the best game ever
made
sartet here we go hey you ready okay me
and Adam against mix and Ken
we are the giant hairy poos okay meow TV
Jana hell yeah
all right now yeah well yeah you know oh
yeah
Jeff back-to-back style you guys I've
seen YMCA yeah we have a police hat all
right let's do this
I hope I hope so - manliness not a good
thing I like you sure you can't say wait
can we kill each other oh man jeez Dave
all damn is a big candidate uh uh chance
killed everyone at the ground yeah me ji
let's talk my house team yeah yeah
that's the free yeah okay come here
I'm a heel I got the ceiling ship I'll
cover you thank for me take for me yeah
man oh they're waiting that's a it's a
trap
I hear them above us okay let's go Oh No
Oh goin right it's way for them
okay run away Felix I'm talking about
Oh those crews team yeah I guess bit
more rounds for that if that's gonna
save one Lambs yeah and then as I have
my ELF right there on something down
here
Oh oh yeah nice I'm a pope and I
murdered the Pope in your veggies okay
hold on team he was protecting the booty
get mixing yeah look at the skillful sub
minx how you doing I'm not so good I see
here hold on I'm gonna shield for us oh
nice don't shoot me in the butt I
thought you'd love a turtle all right
I'm a turtle for it
all right doing it keep doing whatever
you're doing get up get up get up don't
shoot me
thank you yeah get the mints
yes leave the sword alone makes it shoot
him good okay you guys want to change
teams I think we're just perfect
I think in life that's you um okay me
and Ken yeah you all be my team Gary how
do we watch anymore
I'm Kathy okay sweetly how do you do
that
oh there we go okay coming
Oh pinata Padres planted the pinata
I got a mess oh let's get minx - yes
I found her Booga be cool be cool be
cool
No where's makes me giddy like nice your
practice broke Jam all right yeah this
is serious business and still do this
healed
Hey Oh nobody's behind you I'm hiding
brick they'll never find me ivy where
are you hiding
I don't know I mean I wouldn't tell you
okay can wait that can wait there I'll
be right there sugar here okay kill them
kill them up I got that I can I got the
English fix is almost dead get up get up
get up ha let me reload
uh yeah huh noise and what I thought
balls would beep Kim oh yeah alright for
us I hope you enjoyed this episode if
you did go ahead and leave a like it
helps me out a lot
hit subscribe to become a bridge today
also if you're interested in this game
go ahead and [ __ ] the first link in
description you can pay right now for a
limited time whatever you like for the
game you get to support in developers
and charity and that's awesome
Damon do what it's not dealers